they're the most deadly creatures known
to man we're talking about the common
mosquito Seahawk me they are tad quit
her professor shabby marca is a
hungarian astro physicist by training
but today he's less interested in deep
space we have a lot of them in debt and
more focused on shallow water where he
breeds thousands of mosquitoes you're an
astrophysicist running a mosquito farm
absolutely after a close friend
contracted a fatal case of malaria on a
visit to Uganda marker started looking
at how he could use his expertise with
lights and lasers to help eradicate the
disease one that killed half a million
people in 2012 alone the accidentally
discovered a new will behavior pattern
of the mosquito that we can actually
turn them back without harming them
marker and his team found the mosquitoes
sensory and navigation systems were
significantly impaired by infrared light
he was able to turn the insect away by
creating an invisible infrared wall he
then got a million dollar grant in the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
the money has allowed him to visit
Tanzania and to see how his technology
might work in the field so can I go in
or no where do they see the mosquitoes
they are coming up there or there Marcus
says his design could work as a
solar-powered infrared mosquito net
invisible and harmless to humans but
disorientating for mosquitoes several
challenges such as costs still remain
but that isn't stopping marker i also
have four children and in sub-saharan
africa maybe two of them would die from
some disease so I decided that I should
use my expertise to do something
practical something useful as a service
to community